it is all a corrupt
favoritism-based
mess
there's a feeling here in san francisco
that even
talking to any any media that or anyone
is associated with
conservative media media or even
slightly
right of center would be
very detrimental to them
they don't want to be associated they
don't want to make any statements they
don't want to
get the message out other to other
networks other than those that are most
friendly to them to be honest the most
difficult thing is
our city's leadership the elected
leaders and who they appoint to these
different departments
they're all a mess
[Music]
joseph ogden has derelict of duty
he's perpetrated a fraud he is not doing
what he's supposed to do the district
attorney is supposed to charge those
perpetrators of crime hold him
accountable he's letting virtually all
of them go out onto the street not
charging or pleading way way down the
difficulty that we had at the beginning
was to equate crime and lack of
prosecution to the district attorney's
office and who the district attorney was
but
in time with his name in the media
newspaper and and radio and elsewhere
his name is now equated with crime they
come through on a regular basis to
ensure that it's sanitary and they clean
out the pressure wash with soap and
disinfectant the sidewalk
they try and remove the tents if
possible
any garbage needles
but also if there's a special event or
something happening just a couple of
blocks in city hall they want the area
to be cleaned up they don't want the
embarrassment
there are those naysayers that say a
recall is undemocratic and my
immediately my immediate response would
be well not only is it democratic but do
you think that a
an impeachment is democratic and they
say yes okay well then there you go an
impeachment a recall one is more
internal recall is external and because
we're voting on it that makes it
democratic you're being asked a
a choice do we want to keep him in or
remove him i've been here for 20
something years
family friends business associates
investors there's there's so many
wonderful people here in san francisco
that we all have a vested interest we
all support this city with for the
bottom of my heart i would not leave we
are fighting for this city that's why
we're here that's why we're not going to
move we're fighting